i have a guest who he says that uh that
i'm gonna be really boring and that he's
he'd like to save your podcast
all right yeah i mean we're okay here he
comes
what
oh my god triumph i can't believe it i
can't believe how could i miss this the
100
episode of inside conan o'donnell
how could i'm a hundred
congratulations a hundred episodes uh it
just goes to show the old saying is true
yeah podcasts don't get cancelled
that's that's the beauty of podcast they
just keep going
nobody has to listen nobody's in charge
of saying you know what's enough
it's a cute idea it's just too close to
home triumph i can't i can't i can't
listen no no you've got plenty of
listeners people listen
some to every episode and you know what
you know what it's a tribute to conan's
fans and how upsettingly narrow-minded
they are
you know because these people they could
be listening to podcasts about
current events or murders or that's
pretty much it but but no
no
no thank you says the conan fan
i want to listen
to an hour
of editor mark jenkins
talking about the giant
he shaved four frames off the top of
bone and asking mr t
do you like apples
and how it made all the difference
because that section was dragging
that's what i want to listen to
no no i did it again i i kid for a
second
you know what because it's not about the
conan fans i was not kidding about the
conan fans they are freaks i was kidding
about this show
it is a success
you know it's a tribute to it's a
tribute to youtube
that's right the host
mike sweeney sweeney no you're terrific
i have to ask you i have to ask
you used to be a stand-up am i right
didn't you did you used to be a stand-up
let's say yes for the purposes of this
interview i knew it i knew you used to
be a stand-up you know how i could tell
how
because you're hosting a podcast now
that's what people who used to be
stand-ups and not doing
you know they're like well that didn't
work out maybe podcasting
it's easier it's not all me i can be
kind of funny
[Laughter]
i don't have to bring people to the show
no and you know what mike it's so
beautiful there's no booing in podcasts
there's no heckling
it's perfect awkward silences yes but no
booing no heckling
you can cut those down jessie is smart
jesse is smart why is that
because you skipped right past the
unpleasant step of failing at stand up
straight into podcasting
hey man i did with 48 i did three
evening at the improv so really yeah
three
could you send me a sample of bud
friedman's cheese
i heard the first time you didn't wash
your face for a week
because it bugs but freeman's jizz on
his face ladies and gentlemen
all right you know what i did not see
that one coming the hand of my ass
thinks i should stop right now this
whole time all i'm worried about is how
many pages of jokes you have about us
no this was all the hand of my ass sorry
your show's not that important
you know he saves his c material for
podcast
all right this has been a great episode
of uh-huh inside conan o'donnell thank
you
for me
oh my god
damn it boy did he get you guys oh my
god he got it he's got all he didn't see
that coming that for me to poop on you
he really sucked at you you really
thought nailed me that he thought it was
a great episode of inside code